hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast signaling pathways at
your fingertips multiplex IP - targeted
mass spectrometry assay kids for a KT
mTOR pathway it is presented by Bob and
Patel MD a senior R&D scientist for
protein and cell analysis at Thermo
Fisher Scientific I am Julie O'Rourke of
lab routes and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information about our sponsor visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Patel I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you for the
introduction so today we'll talk about
the signaling pathways at your
fingertips
montes XIT - targeted mech spectrometry
has a kit for a KTM tor signaling
pathway
just to kind of give you an overview
I'll start out with background
information on targeted for Yami's and
mass spectrometry and also talk about
the advantages and challenges for
targeted mass spec acids and then moving
on to how do we optimize target
enrichment method as well as verify the
different reagents to develop this
targeted mass spec assay and also how we
can put together in a commercially
available kits for this multiplex IPM
SSA and then I'll kind of talk more
about in the last part of the
presentation how do you get that to the
connotation of this a cake and Rho
pathway targets using these multiplex
IPM s as a kids will compare the Western
blot method with this new IPM FSA's a
workflow as well as how do we develop
these a KTM 2 pathway as a kit and also
talk about the application
so the first question we asked like what
does mass spectrometry protein mass
spectrometry offer to biologists so
currently Western blot is the gold
standard method for study of the
signaling pathway proteins as we know
this throat these pathways have multiple
protein proteins involved in them and at
the same time you have questions that
you know a lot of times you are
targeting this pathway protein so we
must be looking at different drug
combinations with different
concentrations so that generates a lot
of different conditions so with the
Western blot you can only do single
target at a time and if you are
comparing with multiple conditions it
tells you it's a lot a lot of long
process of generating note of Western
blot where that's what biologists are
kind of you know looking at the protein
mass spectrometry and what it offers is
detection of protein isoforms and
modifications that cannot be seen by
other methods as well as identify and
quantify multiple proteins at the same
time identify their pros translation
modifications such as phosphorylation as
well as the protein-protein interaction
and mass spectrometry can be combined
with other antibody dependent methods to
improve the specificity such as like you
know precipitation or flow cytometry can
be used of screening of the mass
spectrometry
so what are the challenges in a mass
spec based proteomics even though mass
spec towards power of identification and
connotation however it will not identify
all the proteins present in a given
sample so the challenge here is because
of the wide dynamic range of abundance
of this protein as an example like you
know plasma has 10 to 12 orders of
magnitude dynamic range in terms of
different proteins present in example
and also even though there has been a
significant amount of progress made in
the last decade for mass spec
instrumentation sensitivity but there
are still limitations in terms of what
you can see in a mass spec there is also
another effect we call ionization
separation where the bundle species will
mask the identic identification of the
low abundant species due to the
ionization separation effect and when
you are doing this with this mass
spectrometry a lot of times to get
missing information for connotation so
it is very important to design the
experiment with the solutions outlined
here where you're using the sample
complexity makes it more palatable and
easier to quantify using Target and
Richmond strategies allow us to carry
biological context through our workflow
and also second most important thing is
the most accurate connotation by mass
spectrometry requires the addition of
stable isotope label internal standard
which can be used to generate standard
curves of known concentration ranges
also it allows you to compare multiple
samples relatively within the same LC
ms/ms run
so knowing this challenging in mind how
do you reduce the sample complexity as I
mentioned by the most commonly used
biological samples of this bio fluid
cells and tissue have a 10 to 12 orders
of magnitude endemic range of related
protein abundance making it nearly
impossible to identify your pendant
proteins
who was abundant one of course we make
it even more difficult by using the
proteolytic enzyme to digest these
thousands of proteins into millions of
peptides that's why a lot of times the
depletion and Richmond and fractionation
methods are used before or after
digestion steps in order to detect this
low abundant proteins as well as their
force transformation modified forms and
I will talk more about optimization of
this enrichment stabbed by immuno
precipitation method before it's a mass
spec application
so how do we get target specific protein
extractions and enrichment we have
optimized this IP to mass spec protocol
and have developed to master
compatibility kit that includes the
protein a/g or sub traveling magnetic
beads it comes with all the reagents
necessary to perform the IP which
includes the lysis buffer optimize
finding methods mass spec compatible
wash buffers and elution buffer and also
this lu8 is compatible with direct in
solution digestion method downstream so
if we kind of walked through on the left
hand side is the typical immune
enrichment methods that we propose where
you start with the light you start
realizing the cells and then you take
the lies in an antibody and allow them
to gain antibody complex form overnight
and day two you bring in the magnetic
beads to capture this antigen-antibody
complex you perform the washes and wash
buffer semester compatible and then you
use the master compatible elution buffer
to elute the antigen of the of the bait
once you get the al you is you speed wet
dry you reduce on collision digest to
generate the pool of peptides and these
peptides are further separated by liquid
chromatography by using their based on
the hydrophobicity factor and as the
each peptide elute of the column they
will get further fragmented and that
generates the fragment spectra for each
peptide and this spectra is match
against the theoretical spectra to
identify the peptide sequences so on a
right hand side in a table multiple
targets from a KTM core pathway where
screen across two kinds of cell line we
then without end richmond and as shown
in a enriched IP column we were able to
get more unique peptides
identified after IP compared to meat
samples so hence enrichment enables the
better detections by mass spectrometry
you
so in a second part of the talk I'll
talk more about how do we develop these
multiplex IP ms essays and I'll start
out with optimization of time for
enrichment protocol and verification of
these targeted mastic S phase and then
development of the commercially
available case
so the workflow for verification of
antibodies by IP MS and development of
targeted MSSA we in a step 1 we select
the targets of interest we select the
relevant cell models and antibodies for
antibody verification by IP MS and in
order to we typically use the messenger
RNA and D protium data generated from
this cancer cell line to identify the
bundles flavor of specific targets in
relevant cell lines to screen in step 2
you know step 2 we perform you know
capture and LCMS analysis where we
select multiple antibodies for a given
target to perform the IP and followed by
lc/ms analysis to verify antibodies
capture efficiency as well as
specificity for each antibody and we try
to select the antibody with the best
capture efficiency to further validate
and use them in a multiplex IP and in
the third step since we are generating
this directed discovery data when we
verify the antibody by IP ms this data
can be used to identify the Condor typic
peptide that can be used with the
targeted prms RMSA using the aqua
peptide
so that I would talk a little bit more
about the targeted mass spec methods
that are commonly used so there are two
methods that are commonly used currently
the field one is selected reaction
monitoring also known as SRM those are
typically done with the triple
quadrupole mass spectrometer and that's
the one is shown on a top panel and in
the bottom panel is the second method
which is known as parallel reaction
monitoring PRM and as those are done
with the thermo scientific you executive
hybrid quadrupole mass spectrometer so
how do these two method works and what
are the common things and differences
between them so SRM method though q1 and
q3 and the first and last mass analyzer
of a triple quadrupole mass spectrometer
are used as a mass filters to isolate a
peptide ion and a corresponding fragment
ion and those are the ones that are
shown in a light green color and the
signal of the fragment ion is then
monitored over the chromatographic
solution time and the specific pair of M
over Z value associated to the precursor
and fragment ions selected are referred
to as transitions so once you get the
transition optimized you can select
multiple transitions for a specific
peptide and you can monitor them for
connotation in a PRM method in the
bottom panel again using the three
quadruple the third quadrupole is
replaced with the high resolution and
accurate math Orbitrap mass analyzer
which allows us to monitor all fragment
ions that can be detected for each
peptide the advantage of monitoring all
fragment ions is ability to identify and
exclude interfering fragment ions from
the unknown samples during the data
analysis steps and that allows us to get
much more accurate connotation for each
peptide
so how do we develop this targeted map
the gases using the aqua baptized so
that you know we enable the absolute
connotation here are the specifications
for aqua de Madrid peptides that we use
they come with the plus or minus five
percent concentration precision more
than 97% peptide purity as well as more
than 99% isotopic enrichment and aqua
peptides are used to generate the
standard curve spanning from 200
céntimos as the highest and point 0
enter moles as a lowest by video
diluting the Aqua Light peptide and
keeping the constant amount of aqua
heavy peptide and that gives you light
over heavy ratio and you plot that
against the concentrations that was used
for light peptide signal dilution and is
an example here the akt1 peptide
seven point standard curve shows that we
get a really good linearity and at least
two to three orders of magnitude dynamic
range and on a right hand side in a
graph we have selected target peptides
from 1280 mTOR pathway target and that
allowed us to get linear connotations
and two to three orders of magnitude
dynamic range by both PR mm as well as
the SRM methods and as you can see here
we were able to get lower limit of
connotations up to point zero eight or
point 23 sentimos set course all the
target peptides and essentially PR a
minus on a method provided the same
level of sensitivity
so once we have validated the antibody
mixtures as well as the baptize this is
kind of outlining the development of the
thermo scientific Shore corn multiplex
it2 targeted NS kids this kits are
developed for simultaneous and Richmond
and connotation of multiple total and
phosphorylated proteins from the a KTM
tor signaling pathway as you can see on
the right hand side there are two tables
the one panel is for a KT total target
and other panel is the phosphorylated
forms of the same a KT mTOR pathway
target now this multiplex panels comes
with the absolute and relative
connotation module so each panel has a
total or phosphorylated has IP and mass
spec number per module that you can do
10 different reactions using the
Bartlett and antibody mix for the do
control lysate step traveling magnetic
beads wash buffer trypsin as well as
other reagents are necessary to do the
math exam program there are two
different connotation modules available
that goes with the ICMS sample prep
module if if you want to get if you want
to do the absolute quantitation you can
use absolute orientation module that
also that comes with the aqua heavy
peptide mixture aqua light peptide
mixture as well as six protein dices as
a matrix and system suitability standard
to assist LC ms/ms
system performance and dynamic range on
a relative orientation module since you
are not generating a standard curve it
only comes with the aqua heavy peptide
mixture and system suitability standard
both this connotation module comes with
the instrument validated instrument
measures as well as the skyline analysis
template
so you know next part of the talk I will
discuss more about how do we get the
absolute connotation of a KTM pro
pathway targets using these s decades
and we'll start with you know looking
going over the Western broad workflow
that's the current gold standard method
and then comparing this method Western
blot with this targeted mass spec assays
as well as the the key characteristics
of these assays and some of the
supporting data with that and then also
talk about the applications of
evaluating these two methods and and ask
questions like can we get absolute
quantitation of a KTM to a pathway
target and how the the connotation
differs between the two measures
so to start off workflow for Western
blotting the Western blotting workflow
also known as the Western workflow is
comprised of three major steps you
separate transfer and detect the purpose
of the virtual workflow is to provide
researchers with the technique to
separate proteins from biological
samples by molecular weight and then
visualize their protein of interest
using a variety of detection matters so
here you can see on a bottom panel there
are some represented you know vex and
Pierce products for each step of this
procedure by integrating the product
portfolio from Norwex and Pierce
Thermo Fisher Scientific is now able to
provide the most comprehensive
end-to-end set of products and
instruments for the Western workflow
now in contrast to Western workflow this
is the workflow for multiplex IPM SSS
we have selected a total 12 to 12 total
and 12 possible related protein targets
from a KTM pro pathway as well as 12
total targets from grass map k pathways
for this multiplex IPM s as a
development we have validated antibody
for each one of this target and use
those and alternator them and created
IPM s module the right size because we
talked about as well as the peptide for
connotations so in a second part of the
workflow that you utilize all these
validated reagents to perform the
multiplex protein amino capture and you
can also use you can automate this
process or on a Kingfisher
instrumentation and then after you have
this mass spec samples of prepare for
mass spec analysis you can perform the
LCMS analyses with either director
discovery or using the targeted PRM SRM
method using the Aqua peptide and in and
targeted mass spec data analysis was
performed using the skyline software to
quantify absolute pollination of each
target in a single mass spec run
so how do Western blot and this IP MS
essays compares with each other
wisdom Lord has been a ghost standard
method for protein connotations and the
advantage of doing the western lot is
the low cost the very easily available
antibody because that have not of
antibodies available there are Western
blot validated it's relatively
standardized one flow and you do it
requires very less amount of samples to
do the Western blot some of the
challenges with this method is the
specificity is lower you know you do not
get absolute quantitation it's a single
flex you have to do single target at a
time it's not very feasible to
investigate the entire pathway in a very
short period of time so that actually
results in our low throughput
if we look at the multiplex I see -
targeted - Peck essays the advantages
allows you since you are performing the
immune enrichment step allows you to get
a better detachment connotation of low
abundance targets with very high
specificity accuracy and reproducibility
also allows you to get the absolute
quantitation by running the standard
curves since it has a multiplexing
capability it also improves the
throughput and with this method allows
you to study the protein-protein
interactions as well as the portion of
special modification analysis and you
can not only investigate the entire
pathway but you can also investigate the
edges and pathways with this method and
I'll talk a bit more about how we study
that different pathways using this
method some of the challenges with this
tech new technology is there are not
that many validated antibodies available
in a market that are verified by IP to
mass spec also it comes with a
relatively high cost the sample prep
matter is a little bit relatively
complex and also since the cost mainly
main costs associated with the LC and MS
instrumentations you do need to have
access to have LC and mass spec
instrumentation with this technique
so so far we talked about validating the
antibodies and validating the peptides
how can we put all these things together
for enrichment of a KTM tour as well as
the RAF or pathway targets on a left
hand side with what will show the
representation of the RAF pathway in
orange and a KTM tour pathway in a
purple color and here these are the most
two important signaling pathways
involved in a cancer biology
targets that we selected are highlighted
with the red asteroid that we develop
the targeted mass the gases for on a
right-hand side the table shows the mass
spec data for total and phosphorylated
pathway targets a KTM Torres pathway
proteins very mini precipitated from
human igf-1 stimulated at CT one one six
lysate using the thermo scientific peers
ms compatible magnetic I take it these
are stripped out in magnetic beads
before the mass spec analysis and as you
can see from the data we were able to
detect 13 isoforms as well as
interacting partners for a KT mTOR wrath
and pi3k targets
not only you detect isoforms and
identity of the target it also we were
able to identify the relevant
phosphorylation site that contains the
possible peptides but also detected for
881 a KT to mTOR - 40 VI k 3 r - r f1
and Rask 1 during the mass spec analysis
and mTOR and interacting proteins from
am throat to complex we're also verified
with this approach
but once we have download these essays
this is kind of giving you a little bit
more in-depth analysis of how the data
looks like by doing the directed
discovery mass spec analysis so the
panel a and B are multi-plex IP MSS a
for total and phosphorylated ATT mTOR
pathway target and panel C is the
multiplex IP Ms for total grass or paved
pathway target and our specification to
get the relative connotation is
identifying at least two unique peptides
for each target and also get more more
than one e to the 6 peptide area for
each one of the unique peptides that
were identified for each target and
using this multiplex I p.m. s-s a kit 12
total and 12 phosphorylated 880 mTOR
pathway proteins as well as 12 total
stress or pathway proteins within reach
from igf-1 stimulated at C T 1 1 6 a
cell line using the BART related
antibody mixtures and the streptavidin
magnetic bead base to mass spec
compatible magnetic IP kids and nano LC
ms/ms analysis for each si resulted in
identification of all these targets
which meets the water dirty connotation
specification and also for each target
we were able to get less than 20% CV
when we calculate the top 3 peptide area
and those are the ones that are shown as
a error part on our knowledge bar graph
as you can see there we were able to get
a really good person CV for each one of
these targeted you want with the
director discovery DDA kind of mastic
analysis
and then we also develop this PRM
connotation for each one of these target
peptide so here on a drop panel
multiple baptize for 12 8 ATM drove a
pair proteins in a on a top panel and
the bottom panel is the rest pathway
target peptides we were able to monitor
them with the linear connotation our
square value of more than 0.996 and more
than three orders of magnitude by doing
the PRM mass spec targeted analysis and
PRM connotation limits of the baptize
for a KTM tour as well as the RAC or
pathway targets are shown here is an on
a bar graph the upper limit of
quantitation for each peptide was at
finder fantomos on column and as you can
see we were able to detect one of these
targets with a lower limit as low as
point zero five and tamos on a column
so how do this overall Esav works when
we combine the multiplex IP as well as
the target lms connotation so this is
kind of showing you the robustness or
the Akt pathway
phospho multiplex IPM fk'd where we had
three different operators and each
operator was performing the IP in
triplicate
from start to finish and we were able to
our specification for PRM connotation is
individual cv should be less than 15%
and the combined series are less than
20% so if you look at here for each
target attribute monitoring we were able
to get the Seavey's we were able to meet
the specs for the person cv as well as
most of the targets after we were able
to monitor them with the list and 10% CV
and if you look at the robustness of the
Akt pathway total multiplex I PMS kid as
you can see here again we were able to
with the three three operators each
operator in a triplicate we were able to
get the series less than 15% for almost
of all the peptides
both of these a KTM tour total and
phosphorylated multiplex panels we were
able to get the series as low like you
know you know in a single digit for lot
of these target baptized
we have this a KTM tour and the wrath
assays we wanted to ask a biological
question where we say we took to a
cancer cell line at CT one one six which
is a colorectal cancer cell line and a
five four nine which is a non small cell
lung cancer cell line and we stimulated
both these cell lines with the U n igf-1
code factor which stimulates the a KTM
true as well as the rest pathway and we
inhibited this pathway using the pi3k
inhibitor ly two nine four zero zero two
and since the H&K inhibitor is actually
kind of common between both the pathway
we wanted to see how the protein
exploration changes downstream as well
as upstream of this pH we can hitter for
a ktml pathway target as well as the
raspberry target and as you see here on
on both signaling pathways targets that
are highlighted with a red box are the
ones that we were monitoring to assess
the protein expressions with a different
condition
as I mention we have developed this
multiplex ICMS essays for a KTM tour as
well as the grass bass guitar kids and
on a top panel what you are seeing is
the best embodies those we're in
scp-1162-j four different phosphorylated
targets the brass 44 so a katie force
will be 70s 6k and for more mTOR from
western glad you can see that that forty
a Katie and p76 K for school related
forms we're up regulated after
stimulation with the human igf-1 and
they are also down regulated after
inhibition with the drug followed by
stimulation with given igf-1 where we
were not seeing significant changes in a
force to enter upon the drug inhibition
and if you look at the bottom panel that
that's the representation of the
multiplex IPM SFA's for a KTM to pathway
target of the blue bar is on untreated
of the gray one is the stimulated and
the blue one is the inhibition followed
by stimulation from the same set1 one
6/10 the same line as you can see that
we are stimulating the lot of this
pathway targets upon the human igf-1
stimulation such as grants for tak TP 70
and 6 km tor what Y is one GSK
3 alpha and beta so all these targets
were upregulated upon emulation
poor out of all these targets we're down
regulated upon the inhibition so first
for a KT one force for P 76k ports for
mTOR phosphorus one they were down
regulated upon pi3k inhibition where
there were not significant change found
in a force for GSK three alpha and beta
as well as the last forwarding so we do
see some correlations between this two
technique Western blot as well as the
multiplex I TMS at phase there is so
variability between these two techniques
for some targets specifically for a KT
and for so mTOR and that could be due to
the antibody specificity because you are
using different antibodies for different
matters one thing I do want to point out
here when you look at the Western blot
fourth word for related akt form since
we know that a KT has three isoforms 80
81 82 and 83 you are measuring the total
amount of all three isoforms on a
Western blot when we do the mass
spectrometry
you can actually distinguish a KD 1 from
a KD 2 and a KD 3 and here we can see
that akt1 is been down regulated upon
the drug inhibition
so just kind of summarize this to cancer
cell line with the stimulation and
inhibition study
see how that protein expression changes
for the a KTM through pathway target and
the rest earth pathway targets in a to
cancel cell line with and without drug
treatment so we didn't see that many
changes in a total a KTM toward pathway
targets in both cell lines regardless
when you stimulate or inhibit and then
stimulate multiple phosphorylated a KTM
through path a protein showed up
regulation upon human igf-1 stimulation
and down regulation in a pH weak
inhibited at CT one one six cancer cell
line except the GSK three alpha and beta
in F i-49 on the other side the
phosphoric KTM pro pathway targets were
upregulated except mTOR but they were
not inhibited upon the drug inhibition
except the phosphor irs-1 when we look
at the the total grass an art pathway
protein should increase in a protein X
expression in a both cancer cell line
and in a phosphorylated forms on the
wrath and all pathway target we didn't
see any change in SCT one one six cell
line but on other side we are seeing
down regulation in a 509 for after the
drug inhibition so we are seeing very
different protein expression changes for
both of this pathway and the the two
cancer cell line
we are seeing cell line dependent
differences in response to the pi3k
inhibition
so just kind of summarizing on the talk
of enrichment by immunoprecipitation
isn't necessary for identification and
mass spec connotation for these low
abundance signaling pathway proteins
also as well as to study the protein
protein interactions and post no special
modifications such as phosphorylation
and the short point Akt pathway
multiplex I PMS kids by using that we
get a higher yield of pathway proteins
and very few nonspecific binding that
allows you to get a better signal to
noise and better connotation for this
pathway targets also this total and
phosphorylated targeted multiplex I TMS
kids allow the simultaneous computation
of multiple a KTM tour and rest or
pathway proteins as well as the
modification in a traditional line
now elucidating the specific pathway
differences between a 549 and SCT 1 1 6
cells who lead us to better understand
and treatment of the lung and colorectal
cancers and the last benchmarking study
of multiplex IDMS assays against the
Western blot using the super signals
with pure substrate in Petrosian I
bright FL 1000 imaging system overall we
do find a good correlation between the
for both a KTM tour and the rest of
pathway proteins however there are some
variability between techniques for some
targets and that could be due to the
different antibodies are used for
different matters and then you also have
the specificity are different for
capturing this target with the different
matters
so that's
have and I would be happy to take any
questions that you have thank you so
much for your time thank you dr. Patel
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for let's get started our first question
is do you use phospho peptides for the
floss for a fake it and non-modified
peptide for the total assay kits
that's a really good question so we have
spent a lot of time understanding the
quantitation of these phosphorylated
forms of targets using the possible
peptide and the challenge we see is a
lot of times to possible peptide
analytically they are not really good
for connotation so to answer the
questions what we do is we use the
antibody that are specific for the
phosphorylated form of target but I
could enrichment and digestion respite
in with the non modified version of the
unique peptides for each one of these
targets so we don't use the possible
peptide for connotation we use the
native form of unmodified peptides that
we know has a very really good dynamic
range has a really good low limit of
connotations and gives you much highly
accurate and precise connotation for
both total and possible kids so the both
Total SA and the phosphorus a are
utilizing the same unique peptide and we
rely on different antibody to capture
total and the phosphorylated forms at
the protein level thank you
do the math back si kids work with
tissue and Mouse xenograft samples
of es so we I haven't shown any data on
those but we have used this same asset
on a normal as well as the tumor tissue
lies it as well as the mouth xenograft
samples and you were able to we were
able to identified a lot of these
targets from the cancer or T word tissue
lies it as well as or most of the
targets in our mouth you know grab
samples does it require a different life
a preparation oh yes so the cell lysate
of this pretty much you know
straightforward cell lysis you know with
the tissue samples you do have to you
can still use the same license buffer
but you have to perform the reasoning
the tissue and then organization
followed by lysis using the same IP
lysis buffer and it works it works well
with that method great how does this
protein level in you know enrichment
method compared to the peptide level
enrichment so we are performing at the
protein level amino enrichment by
validating the antibody by IDMS method
you can also generate the antibody for
very unique peptide for each one of this
target and perform the take the lysate
digest and do the peptide level
enrichment of the advantage of doing
protein level enrichment is not only you
can reach your target but you can also
get the protein protein in fact
interactions as well as the isoforms
information and also you can get the
Tokyo Metro information about the
unmodified and modified forms of the of
the protein level
great thank you looks like we have time
for one more question into two-parter so
the first part is how do you verify the
antibody selectivity and capture
efficiency by IP MS
so I kind of went very quickly on a
workflow but typically we start with we
have done extensive deep dive deep
proteome analysis for 12 cancer cell
lines so we kind of know that Olivia
abundance of a lot of these important
signaling pathway targets in each one of
the cell line and we start with
selecting multiple antibodies that are
commercially available for specific
target and we screen all of them from
the control cell line that we know there
is a medium relatively medium abundance
of that particular target by using the
mass spec compatible IP kids that are
that utilizing the protein a/g magnetic
beads and once you run all the sample
side by side when you analyze the mass
spec data what we do is we calculate the
full enrichment of the intended target
by comparing with control IP and higher
the pole enrichment we get we tend to
select the antibody that gives you the
higher fallin treatment
and although we have I'm sorry
there is another continuation from there
that we also have developed a new method
where we not only look at the enrichment
of the target but as well as the epitope
by we can map the epitope binding site
for each one of these antibodies that we
have validated so we can confirm that
these antibodies indeed binding to the
to the epitope that is designed for and
it's valuable it's very valuable for the
for the phospho specific antibody
thank you dr. Pell here's the last part
how do you select peptides to use for
each target quantitation
so what once we verify this antibody by
I PMS matter we use the same data to ask
questions what are the unique factors do
we do we see in a mass spec and we tends
to use the data and analyze them and ask
questions which baptize has a very good
response factor in a mass spec as well
as reproducible and stable and then we
screen multiple peptides to assess their
linearity stability response factors we
order them in a in aqua format and then
select at least two target peptides for
each one of these targets in our in our
final essay I would like to once again
thank dr. Patel for his presentation I
would also like to thank Thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through September of
2019 you will receive an email from
laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye